et pour tous ceux qui doivent encore
gardé leurs rideaux baissés il reste
cette initiative originale d'un jeune
tourangeau vincent pichon c'est son nom
a eu l'idée de réunir dans un clip vidéo
une trentaine de commerçants de la
métropole tourangelle qui ont peu de
visibilité sur internet
pendant deux jours il s'est rendu dans
leurs boutiques pour les aider à
communiquer le résultat
le voici aurélie renault n'a pas de
pression comme au théâtre
vincent dirige ses acteurs d'un jour
face à l'objectif des commerçants
la séquence est tournée dans cette
boutique de bijoux du vieux tours puis
les tournages vont s'enchaîner
cette fois vincent et dans le quartier
velpeau chez un artisan fleuriste à
chaque séquence
il demande aux commerçants de délivrer
un message aujourd'hui encore plus
qu'hier nous sommes le lien entre tous
les tourangeaux soyons tous solidaires
restons soudés il n'ya qu'ensemble que
nous traverserons cette période
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier nous
sommes le lien entre tous les tours aux
gens de votre soutien fera la différence
alors continuez
à faire vivre vos commerces de proximité
gardons l'esprit festif pour ces fêtes
de fin d'année et ensemble faisant
rayonner notre ville ils sont une
trentaine à prendre la parole
la vidéo est postée sur les réseaux
sociaux pour soutenir les boutiques au
niveau local fleuriste restaurateurs
boutique de jouets de décoration les
commerçants ont répondu à l'appel de
vincent sur la toile des chaussettes
démarche cheval exceptionnel quoi et
prendre du temps pour nous pour essayer
de nous de nous en sortir encore un peu
plus enfin c'est juste c'est juste
remarquable vidéastes professionnels
vincent a réalisé ce clip bénévolement
une initiative à laquelle il a pensé le
jour où le président de la république a
annoncé leur confinement
le seul point commun que je peux avoir
avec le commerçant effectivement c'est
que moi je suis prestataires de services
et que je me retrouve aussi dans la même
situation que j'ai des événements qui
sont annulés des prestations qui
s'annulent eh ben il faut il faut
rebondir en fait il faut pouvoir se dire
j'ai un petit peu de temps disponible
donc comment je peux utiliser ce temps
au mieux pour pouvoir aider les
tourangelles et les tourangeaux a à
gagner en visibilité
et voilà je le fais bénévolement parce
que parce que ça me tient à coeur et que
je trouve que c'est le même fin c'est ma
mission je dois le faire quoi c'est à
moi de le faire avec cette vidéo vincent
devient le porte voix du consommer local
il espère que son clip incitera les
tourangeaux à faire travailler les
commerçants de la métropole